ja so ist es meine damen und herren eine
beeindruckende gedenkstunde zu den
dingen die lange hinter uns liegen und
unvergessen bleiben werden aber die welt
ist nicht viel friedlicher geworden der
ukraine konflikt wird hier gleich die
abgeordneten beschäftigen ich kann ihnen
nicht ganz genau sagen zur sekunde damen
und herren ob wie ursprünglich geplant
das programm darin um halb losgeht ich
nehme mal an dass die umbaumaßnahmen
etwas länger dauern und es bis viertel
vorgeht und deswegen werden wir noch
zeit haben für ein interview zu diesem
thema ukraine der kanzler aus hamburg
hat einmal gesagt lieber 100 stunden
umsonst verhandeln als eine minute
schießen das war natürlich helmut
schmidt und er hat gleichzeitig den nato
doppelbeschluss durchgesetzt auch gegen
seine partei weil er auf augenhöhe auf
stärke verhandeln wollte dieses probiert
im moment auch die westliche
staatengemeinschaft unter führung der
amerikaner die nato und gestern war ein
entscheidender tag da haben nämlich die
amerikaner unter hat die nato das
antwortschreiben übersendet an wladimir
putin der ja forderungen gestellt hatte
in richtung westliche gemeinschaft zum
beispiel dass die ukraine nicht in die
nato eintreten da auf weitere staaten
dort nicht die ost-erweiterung dort
nicht stattfinden darf und dass waffen
zurück gezogen werden sollen die antwort
der amerikaner war die meisten
bedingungen können wir so nicht
akzeptieren über abrüstung können wir
jederzeit gerne verhandeln was heißt das
jetzt dass würde ich fragen meine beiden
heutigen gäste nils schmid der
außenpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion und jürgen hardt in der
gleichen funktion für die cdu/csu herr
schmid was heißt denn das nun was die
amerikaner und die nato da herr putin
geantwortet haben sind wir einem krieg
in der ukraine jetzt näher oder hat die
diplomatie dann noch mal die oberhand
gewonnen also mein eindruck ist dass in
den letzten zehn tagen die diplomatie
deutlich die oberhand gewonnen hat es
gab verschiedene gesprächs formate
angefangen von bilateralen treffen der
amerikaner und der russen über den nato
russland rat wo s10e treffen bis hin zu
formaten europäer und
rainer und russen indirekt im gespräch
waren zuletzt das treffen gestern im
normandie format frankreich russland
ukraine und deutschland auf ebene der
regierungsberater
das zeigt an die diplomatie gewinnt an
stärke und wichtig für uns ist dass in
dem antwortschreiben jetzt ein putin wir
in der sache klar sind aber
dialogbereitschaft gezeigt haben in der
sache klar heißt es kann keine
einflusssphären geben innerhalb europas
es gibt keine abgestufte souveränität
europäischer staaten russland muss
akzeptieren dass die ukraine aber auch
die osteuropäischen mitgliedsstaaten der
eu und der nato volle souveränität haben
und russland kann deshalb nicht darauf
setzen dass wir die ordnung von 1990 mit
der charta von paris einfach über bord
werfen sondern wenn dann gibt es
gespräche über abrüstung und
rüstungskontrolle und es ist für die
europäische sicherheit auch unbedingt
erforderlich daher hat die russen nahmen
mittlerweile so bricht beobachter
120000 truppen zusammengezogen an der
ukrainischen grenze
herr putin hat jetzt die antwort auf
seine sicherheitsforderungen die er
gestellt hat vielleicht dem wissen dass
die antwort so lauten könnte wo stehen
wir jetzt in diesem konflikt hat herr
putin jetzt schon was erreicht weil die
amerikaner die nato sagt lass uns reden
über abrüstung was ja immer gut ist oder
ist er enttäuscht dass eben die nato
sich weiter nach osten ausdehnen kann
wenn das die staaten dort wollen weil
die nato dahinter steht
zunächst einmal möchte ich feststellen
dass der druck den putin mit seinen
streitkräften an der ukrainischen grenze
ausübt ja eher den wunsch der menschen
in der ukraine zum westen und zur nato
zu gehören verstärkt also wir wären ja
gar nicht in dieser situation russland
wäre gar nicht in dieser situation das
gilt im übrigen auch für georgien und
andere ehemalige sowjet-republiken wenn
russland sich wesentlich freundlicher
mit diesen staaten auseinander setzen
würde insofern provoziert putin im
grunde das was er verhindern will durch
sein verhalten und das ist etwas was wir
deutlich machen müssen und was auch er
und sein umfeld begreifen muss dass er
letztlich
russland entfernt von der übrigen welt
ein stück weit auch isoliert ich glaube
in den letzten wochen ist auch deutlich
geworden dass dieser militär aufmarsch
keine unterstützung in der welt findet
auch kein verständnis für die russische
position und umgekehrt dass er damit
letztlich alle immac wenig macht die
ansonsten ja vielleicht eine rolle
zwischen russland und der europäischen
union und den besten einnehmen könnten
also insofern glaube ich dass stimmig
nicht mit voll und ganz zu die letzten
tage haben schon das diplomatisch
gewicht eher auf die seite der ukraine
und des westens verlegt eben aus diesen
gründen er hat keine unterstützung in
der welt für seine position allerdings
hat er einen truppenaufmarsch an der
grenze organisiert der mittlerweile ein
großteil der gesamten russischen
streitkräfte umfasst
dabei nicht ab wenn ich seine blick auf
das missgeschick so kann man das
natürlich sehen herr schmid auf der
anderen seite es ist ja so dass
tatsächlich schweden und finnland
überlegen ob die nato mitglieder lieber
werden dass ich ihnen alles zu
unheimlich was putin da macht damit
würde putin eher das gegenteil von dem
erreichen was er will aber putin ist ja
nicht dumm kann es sein dass der
russische präsident dieses ganze
veranstaltet hat und jetzt die einen
antwortbrief der nato und der amerikaner
nutzt um zu sagen jetzt marschieren wir
da ein in den don was weil die anderen
wollen es ja nicht anders also ich sehe
jetzt nicht einen unmittelbaren
einmarsch bevorstehen aber die
bedrohungslage bleibt ernst sowie
kollege hartz festgestellt hat die
russischen truppen sind immer noch da
sind hoch mobilisiert und damit ist zwar
die diplomatie jetzt wieder in der
vorhand aber leider haben die russen
noch keinen schritt zur entspannung
beigetragen und es wäre sehr wichtig
dass russland diesen hohen drucken
aufzug zurücknimmt und dass wir im dorf
selber in der ost ukraine einen
verlässlichen waffenstillstand bekommen
und das müssen jetzt auch die nächsten
schritte sein dass wir normandie format
so ganz praktische de
eskalationsschritte vornehmen waffen in
flechtungen von truppen entlang der
kontakt linie in der ostukraine und vor
allem dieser russische truppenabzug die
motivation von putin aus meiner sicht
ist klar er versucht den westen zu
testen die geschlossenheit des westens
zu testen und er braucht außenpolitische
stärke demonstrationen um nach innen die
reihen zu schließen schließlich ist
russland im inneren alles andere als
besonders innovativ und wirtschafts
stark seit 20 jahren sehen wir so was
wie stabile stagnation die abhängigkeit
von öl und gas ist unverändert hoch die
innovationskraft der russischen
wirtschaft ist niedrig die
meinungsvielfalt die zivilgesellschaft
wird unterdrückt was für ihn zählt ist
die erhaltung der macht und dass wieder
mit außenpolitische stärke erreichen
dass norman liefern format das ist ja
insofern positiv als das gestern wieder
am verhandlungstisch verhandelt wurde
wenn auch nur auf kleiner ebene mit
außenpolitischen berater das war ja auch
schon mal anders dort sitzt nämlich die
großen gemeinsam mit den ukrainern und
an einem tisch und die franzosen und die
deutschen moderieren das ganze man hat
sich jetzt erst dann in paris darauf
verständigt das waren wohl sehr
schwierige gespräche war zu hören dass
man hat sich verständigt man will sich
in 14 tagen in berlin wieder treffen
aber die russen haben auch klar gemacht
es muss bewegung dahin die ukraine
müssen die eine oder andere forderung
gegenüber den separatisten haben
verändern es geht da zum beispiel um die
wahlen die müssen erst stattfinden bevor
die ukraine wieder dieses gebiet zurück
bekommen und an den grenzen kontrollen
ausüben können dass es zumindest die
forderung der russen und interessant ist
dass die russen sich dort gar nicht als
aggressor sehen sondern als vermittler
für die separatisten sie tun so als wenn
sie gar nicht partei wehren hat in
dieses format überhaupt die möglichkeit
mit winzigen schritten den frieden zu
retten also ich finde auch an dem
gestrigen ergebnis gut dass man gesagt
hat - zwei also das was bereits
vereinbart worden ist und was ja auch
hier in berlin vor einigen jahren in
einem gipfel noch einmal bekräftigt
worden ist dass das weiter die grundlage
ist und ich sehe auch keine alternative
zu dieser vorgehensweise
allein diese schutzmacht rolle die putin
sich an maas gegenüber menschen in einem
gebiet in einem anderen land das
erinnert mich halt fatal an das
zwanzigste jahrhundert wo das ja ganz
oft als argument für kriegerische
einmarschieren verwendet wurden nicht
zuletzt hat hitler seine
angriffskriege auch begründet mit diesem
angeblichen schutzbedürfnis von
deutschen in anderen ländern das klingt
total schrill in meinen ohren und ich
finde wir sollten als deutschland einen
starken beitrag dazu leisten dass putin
kleist der westen ist geschlossen und
visa frage und wenn ich eine kleine
kritik an marken darf an der schwierigen
situation in der die bundesregierung es
ich hätte mir gewünscht dass der
deutsche bundeskanzler in den letzten
tagen unsere partner in mittelosteuropa
zum beispiel nato partner aber auch eu
staaten finnland schweden die sich
bedroht fühlen baltikum dass er sie
besucht das er mit den regierungschefs
dort spricht dass er den menschen das
gefühl gibt ihr könnt euch auf
deutschland verlassen denn das ist so
man kann sich auf deutschland verlassen
aber in der art und weise wie die
bundesregierung das im augenblick nach
außen trägt sehe ich ganz klar
verbesserungsbedarf ich würde da auch
gerne unterstützen das ist ein guter
ratschlag wenn sie so wollen jetzt keine
parteipolitische kritik ich aber es wird
mehr von der welt erwartet von unserer
bundesregierung was diese klaren signale
kommen wir vielleicht gleich noch drauf
ich wollte nur zurückkommen auf die
diplomatie hammer chrome wird morgen mit
herrn putin
telefonieren makro war anfang der woche
hier bei olaf scholz und man hat gesagt
also putin wenn du da einmal hier ist
das wird mächtige konsequenzen haben
auch wirtschaftlicher art das klingt von
außen immer so ein bisschen wie die
drohung mit ja mit was was passiert dann
es wird ein boden preisgeben für
russland im falle einer militärischen
aggression und 1 müssen wir einfach mal
festhalten russland ist in dem konflikt
in der ost ukraine nicht vermittler
sondern partei ostern steht auf der
seite der aggressoren die separatisten
in der ost ukraine könnten ohne
militärische und finanzielle und
politische unterstützung moskaus gar
nicht sich halten und deshalb kommt es
jetzt auf die vermittlungsbemühungen von
deutschland und frankreich das in die
beiden vermittler in dem normandie
format an und deshalb ist diese
abstimmung zwischen makro und stolz so
existenziell auf die sicherheit der
ukraine die sanktionen die auf dem tisch
liegen sind sehr breit und es ist gut
dass putin sich nicht genau ausrechnen
kann wenn ich das tue passiert jenes
deshalb geht es um sanktionen im bereich
der energie einschließlich des stopps
der pipeline nord stream zwei es geht um
banken und um den finanzsektor der
sanktioniert werden dann bis hin zum
ausschluss des russischen der russischen
wirtschaft von dem zahlungssystems hilft
es geht um weitere sektorale sanktionen
zb um hightech mutter und es geht auch
um persönliches sanktionen der
verantwortlichen in moskau für den fall
einer aggression damit ist klar es wäre
eine enorme strategische preis von
russland zu bezahlen diese abschreckungs
kulisse ist glaubwürdig und eröffnet uns
dann die spielräume für diplomatie die
ja in den letzten tagen zum glück größer
geworden sind von einem sozialdemokraten
so dahingesagt nord stream 2 gehört
jetzt auch zu dem paket seit einigen
wochen auch für die sozialdemokratie
sicherlich kein leichter weg aber für
uns alle auch nicht hart weil diese
wirtschaftlichen sanktionen das wird
immer so gesagt sind wenn ich doch
abhängig zb von den gaslieferungen da
gibt es ja schon nord stream 1 und wir
kriegen 55 prozent unseres gases aus der
aus russland können wir so einfach sagen
ihr werdet sanktioniert und
dann schneiden uns ins eigene fleisch
anschluss
sanktionspolitik ist
wenn man darauf hat sich militärisch
einzugreifen das einzige mittel mit dem
wir druck ausüben können und deswegen
müssen wir im zweifel zu diesen
sanktionen stehen so wie wir das im
übrigen auch in anderen fragen nicht
gegenüber russland aber also auch gehen
bewusst hat war auch gegenüber anderen
ländern gemacht haben ich glaube aber
dass wir als deutschland schon klar
darüber sein müssen wenn wir jetzt nicht
klare kante zeigen und wenn wir jetzt
nicht klar bei unseren prinzipien
bleiben und eben uns als unabweisbar
darstellen dann würden wir früher oder
später einen viel höheren preis bezahlen
müssen das ist das große risiko was sich
damit verbinden würde wenn wir jetzt
meinen das löst sich auf meiner mein
wunsch ist natürlich dass dieser
konflikt sich diplomatisch beilegen
lässt und dann ist alles möglich mit
russland neue abrüstungsverhandlungen
vielleicht auch eine verbindliche zusage
über stationierung von nato truppen und
russischen truppen im grenzgebiet
zwischen russland und nato
langfristige gaslieferverträge
alles diese dinge einbeziehung russlands
in eine wirtschaftsordnung wir haben mal
den plan gehabt eine freihandelszone von
lissabon bis wladiwostok als europäische
union plus andere plus russland das sind
alles träume und möglichkeiten die wir
erfüllen können wenn russland das nur
will das ist unser angebot was auf den
tisch legt und dies untermauert das
dialogangebot ganz besonders dass wir
also nicht nur im luftleeren raum
operieren sondern dass das konkrete
vorschläge geht was man tun könnte auch
im sinne des russischen volkes er
spielte ich habe gerade helmut schmidt
am anfang zitiert in der tat des
verhandeln besser als kämpfen dazu muss
man auch sozusagen die position haben um
zu verhandeln man hat so ein bisschen
das gefühl dass vladimir putin angela
merkel so lange sie noch da war als
verhandlungspartnerin sehr wohl
anerkannt hat in osteuropäischen ländern
ist es jetzt so dass die neue deutsche
bundesregierung gewaltig unter druck
gerät mit ihrer doch sehr klaren haltung
zu waffenlieferungen
und gestern natürlich der vorfall die
ukraine hatte gebeten um 100000 helm und
schutzwesten und die
verteidigungsminister erinnert 5000
helme zur verfügung gestellt und gesagt
das sei ein ganz deutliches zeichen
wir stehen an eurer seite haben sie
verständnis dafür dass nicht nur die
ukraine sondern auch viele
osteuropäische staaten das als hohn
empfinden
ja ich habe verständnis für den wunsch
der ukraine nach militärischer
sicherheit und auch nach unterstützung
in dieser lage wir haben deshalb
wird es zu recht diskutiert bloß für uns
kommen gerade weil wir eine
vermittlerrolle in der normandie format
zusammen mit frankreich eingeräumt
bekommen haben kommen waffenlieferung
nicht in frage weil das würde ja diese
vermittlungsbemühungen die wir gerade in
gang gesetzt haben untergraben dass wir
die ukraine vielfältig wirtschaftlich
und finanziell unterstützen und das auch
noch bereit sind auszubauen weil ja die
wirtschaftslage in der ukraine auch
leidet unter der jetzigen situation und
bedrohung das ist völlig klar das werden
wir auch weiter tun und wir bieten nach
innsbruck rheinischen freunde deshalb
auch um verständnis dass wir bei der
einen frage vielleicht nicht ganz so
viel leisten können wie sie es wünschen
aber in anderen bereichen viel mehr tun
als alle anderen denn wir wollen dass
die ukraine als selbstständiges land
europäisches dann seinen eigenen weg
gehen kann und alles was wir mit
russland besprechen darf eben die
souveränität nicht nur der ukraine
sondern auch unseren osteuropäischen
partner nicht infrage stellen was
besonders wichtig wäre wäre dass wir zu
einer verabredung in europa über die
begrenzung der konventionellen
streitkräfte und truppen kommen das wird
die bedrohungslage auch gerade zwischen
russland und den nachbarstaaten deutlich
reduzieren das wäre glaubt ein wichtiger
verhandlungsgegenstand für die kommenden
gespräche keine waffenlieferungen die
ukraine das hat auch die alte regierung
immer vertreten auf der außenpolitiker
jürgen hardt vor zwei tagen habe ich ein
interview gelesen haben sie ihre meinung
verändert ist es ja so dass die
franzosen die briten waffenlieferungen
in aussicht stellen wenn es dann losgeht
im moment haben sie das ja auch noch
nicht getan die deutschen sagen radikal
wir liefern keine waffen
sie haben jetzt ihre meinung verändert
warum wir haben diese position der
damaligen großen koalition seit 2014
durch getragen weil wie immer der
meinung waren die militärische
eskalation dominanz also dass die
möglichkeit des militärs zu eskalieren
liegt bei russland und wir würden durch
eine aufrüstung der ukraine im zweifel
da nur einen anreiz leisten jetzt
stellen wir leider fest seit spätestens
anfang letzten jahres dass russland
diese signale völlig missdeutet und
seinerseits massiv an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze aufrüstet
und gruppen zusammen zieht das ist eine
völlig veränderte lage und ich finde es
ziemlich zynisch wenn wir den menschen
in der ukraine sagen ihr habt zwar
unseren warmen händedruck aber wenn es
ganz konkret darum geht euch zu schützen
da helfen wir euch nicht deswegen finde
ich dass defensivwaffen anforderungen
der ukraine sorgfältig geprüft werden
müssen das muss immer geprüft das sind
dass waffen die russland als bedrohung
für russland empfinden wo es das würde
ich ausschließen aber das was rein
defensive sollte man machen und robert
habeck hat vor noch nicht einmal acht
monaten in der ukraine gesagt den wunsch
nach defensivwaffen dem könnte man wohl
schwerlich widersprechen und jetzt ist
er vize kanzler und für rüstungsexporte
zuständigen bundesminister und er kann
sich in der regierung mit dieser
position offensichtlich nicht
durchsetzen nein weil die linke waren in
grünen aber auch bei der spd dass
blockiert aber es wird sicherlich nicht
entschieden werden durch deutsche
waffenlieferungen herr schmid das ist
ein ärgerlicher faktor weil die deutsche
außenpolitik damit so ein bisschen auch
in diskreditiert wird olaf scholz reist
jetzt im kommenden monat erstmalig ich
glaube am 17 februar nach amerika und
die amerikanische administration sie
hält ja noch voll zu deutschland
zumindest offiziell und sagt wir sind da
sehr zufrieden wenn es darauf ankommt
werden auch die deutschen springen wie
wichtig ist diese deutsch-amerikanische
achse für das problem als für uns und
auch für kann stolz ist diese
transatlantische freundschaft und
partnerschaft das rückgrat europäische
und deutsche sicherheit auch natürlich
unsere mitarbeiter und mit wirkungen in
der nato und wir haben gerade auch in
den letzten wochen bewiesen dass wir
unseren verpflichtungen in der nato voll
nachkommen wir haben
zugesagt dass zusätzliche flugzeuge die
ostflanke der nato in rumänien absichern
und deshalb ist dieser besuch der
antrittsbesuch von kanzler scholz ein
ganz wichtiges ereignis und
unterstreicht noch einmal dass auch wenn
im normandie format ist erstmal auf
deutschland und frankreich ankommt wir
uns auf die unterstützung der amerikaner
zur deeskalation in der ukraine
verlassen können wenn der beste schutz
für die ukraine ist ein erfolg dieser
diplomatischen bemühungen ja und da will
ich nochmal nachfragen diplomatische
bemühungen wie kann es denn jetzt weiter
gehen der ball liegt bei herrn putin was
vermuten sie mit ihrer erfahrung wird ja
den ball noch einmal aufnehmen und
tatsächlich versuchen waffen dort aus in
der aus der nähe seines bereiches der
nato zu verbannen sozusagen sich selber
zurückziehen das als faustpfand und
damit einen erfolg einheimsen oder ist
er wirklich schon so weit und sagt die
sind alle so schwach wir marschieren war
da eben den don was ein ich hoffe dass
nicht ich glaube dass auch putin kein
interesse daran haben kann an einer
militärischen lösung dieses konflikts
ich glaube auch das wäre der anfang vom
ende seiner herrschaft war das enorm
teuer ist weil es auch ein enormes
risiko für russland und die russischen
streitkräfte wäre und für die isolation
russland natürlich auch ein
wichtiger punkt russland hätte große
schwierigkeiten wirtschaftlich und
politisch sich von einer solchen
völkerrechtswidrigen aktion zu erholen
also insofern glaube ich dass er schon
weiß wie hoch der preis ist ich setze da
bei diesem ganzen prozess auf das
normale format und bei der kontrolle und
überwachung und umsetzung und auch bei
der frage der wahlen in den
entsprechenden umstrittenen gebieten
setze ich darauf dass die osze wieder
stärker eine rolle nimmt also die
organisation für sicherheit in europa in
denen ja die amerikaner und die kanadier
also nordamerika auch mitglied sind eine
entscheidende rolle aber das hat ja
worauf eigentlich in abrede gestellt der
außenminister er hat gesagt dass man die
format ist gut der kontakt mit den
amerikanern ist gut an europa und an der
ostsee hat er kein kein interesse glaubt
nicht dass diese verhandlungen zu etwas
führen weil so viele stimmen dort
miteinander dann sich erstmal
koordinieren müssen in der tat dies
normandie mord in 14 tagen in berlin ist
vielleicht das format was den krieg noch
verhindern kann zumindest für die
nächsten 14 tage oder sehen sie das
anders es kommt erstmal auf das nochmal
die format an das ist richtig weil wenn
es um den waffenstillstand geht
beispielsweise müssen wir im normandie
format konkrete verabredungen treffen
wenn es um humanitäre lösung für die
bevölkerung in den besetzten gebieten
und in der grenze der zur kontakt linie
geht dann kommt es auf das comedy format
an allerdings hat die osze eine wichtige
unterstützende rolle ist ja es ist die
einzige internationale organisation die
in dem gebiet tätig ist mit einer
beobachtungskommission leider wird sie
immer wieder behindert auch von den
separatisten und es war wichtig dass sie
diese rolle voll ausüben kann ich wollte
der usc das nicht absprechen aber der
außenminister aus russland tut dass herr
lauda sagt er erwartet sich da nichts
das gespräch mit den amerikanern was
hier an steht und das gespräch eben hier
in berlin das könnte entscheiden meine
damen und herren und alle sind die
hoffnungen dass die diplomatie noch
nicht am ende ist aber wir sind jetzt am
ende hier mit unserem gespräch über
diesen punkt leicht lieber tieren die
parlamentarier im parlament darüber
vorher gibt es hier noch wichtige wahl
nicht geben bärbel bas hat bereits platz
genommen